und jetzt das heute journal
mit kaiser richter und christian sievers
guten abend hinein wir beginnen mit
einer traurigen wahrheit die der chef
der deutschen lufthansa heute
aussprechen musste wir brauchen das geld
vom staat sonst droht uns die
zahlungsunfähigkeit
carsten spohr erfolgsverwöhnt stämmiger
auftritt klare kante heute sagt der mann
fast kleinlaut er sei dem staat dankbar
wir alle haben die lufthansa gerettet
mit insgesamt neun milliarden euro
bis zuletzt mussten die lufthanseaten
zittern auf der außerordentlichen
hauptversammlung ein deutscher
milliardär hätte noch alles kippen
können heute mit seinen stimmen
doch dann bekommt spur sein go ready for
take off und damit geht die arbeit erst
richtig los für den ehemaligen
überflieger in einer branche die am
boden liegt dominik löschmeister
berichtet applaus um sich mut zu machen
denn es geht um ihre jobs
deshalb sind sie zur frankfurter
lufthansa zentrale gekommen
auch steffi rotes dabei seit 18 jahren
flugbegleiterin
sie hofft dass die aktionäre dem
rettungspaket zustimmen
natürlich menschen gibt die das nicht so
nachvollziehen kann wie viel herz auch
hinter dieser firma steckt und wie viel
familie das eigentlich auch bedeutet
sind 138.000 mitarbeiter weltweit und
das ist einfach ein zu hause hinter den
fassaden derweil das endspiel im poker
um die lufthansa rettung selbst in der
schwersten krise
trotz der kranich noch vor
selbstbewusstsein wirtschaft
stabilisierungs beschleunigungsgesetz
das könnte man auch gute lufthansa
gesetz nennen oder starke lufthansa
gesetz doch ohne staatsgeld droht die
insolvenz deshalb fordern vorstand und
aufsichtsrat eindringlich von den
aktionären eine zustimmung wir wollen
eine insolvenz mit all ihren folgen
unbedingt vermeiden
wenn eine insolvenz der lufthansa auch
in der sonderform des schutzschirm
verfahrens hätte für sie meine damen und
herren in nahezu vollständigen verlust
ihres aktienkapitals zufolge
lange zeit sah es so aus als ob die
lufthansa rettung scheitern würde
an großaktionär heinz hermann thiele der
erst im märz eingestiegen ist jetzt rund
15 prozent der aktien hält viele gilt
als erfolgreicher unternehmer beinhart
in verhandlungen auch mit gewerkschaften
so ist sein unternehmen knorr bremse
nicht tarifgebunden den staatseinstieg
bei der lufthansa kritisierte der
79-jährige eindeutiges geworden dass
herr thiele nur seine eigenen ziele
verfolgt er hat nie den schulterschluss
mit anderen aktionären oder mit anderen
gruppen gesucht er hatte nur seinen weg
im fokus das schreckgespenst der
insolvenz ist sorgte für bewegung bei
den kosten mit der
flugbegleitergewerkschaft hat die
lufthansa ein sparpaket von einer halben
milliarde euro vereinbart mit piloten
und dem bodenpersonal wird aktuell noch
verhandelt ja mein kündigungsschutz für
vier jahre für die mitarbeiter in der
kabine abschließen können ein anderer
seite gibt es einschnitte für die
mitarbeiter vor allem in der
altersvorsorge die vereinigung cockpit
und die piloten sind fest dazu
entschlossen einen beitrag zu leisten
wir haben eine deutliche summe angeboten
wir haben kompromissbereitschaft gezeigt
wir wollen auch verantwortung tragen für
dieses unternehmen
98 prozent zustimmung am ende für die
staatshilfe die lufthansa pleite
abgewendet doch bis deutschlands größte
airline wieder so erfolgreich ist wie
vor der korona pandemie werden wohl
jahre vergehen
die lufthansa soll wieder richtig
fliegen für wirecard kommt heute das
ende schnell und mit schrecken der
zahlungsdienstleister zu seinen besten
zeiten fünf mal soviel wert an der börse
wie die lufthansa heute ist pleite nie
zuvor hat es in der dax riege von
deutschlands unternehmen einen derart
rasanten absturz gegeben
fast 6.000 beschäftigte weltweit müssen
sich größte sorgen um ihren job machen
sehr sehr viele kleinaktionäre sitzen
jetzt auf praktisch wertlosen papieren
der grund ist nicht corona sondern ein
fall für die staatsanwaltschaft verdacht
auf luftbuchungen manipulierte bilanzen
milliarden betrug in diesem
wirtschaftsskandal sieht niemand gut aus
nicht der vorstand nicht die
kontrolleure im aufsichtsrat und bei der
finanz
auf sicht nicht der standort deutschland
wie jürgen wollmann berichtet überzeugt
hat der viele und das viele jahre lang
markus braun fast zwei jahrzehnte
vorstandsvorsitzender
er führte die wirecard ag in die
spitzengruppe der deutschen
großunternehmen den dax30 eine
spektakuläre firmengeschichte aber noch
spektakulärer der absturz der firma bei
münchen erstmals meldet ein dax konzern
insolvenz an vorwürfe hat er es schon
lange gegeben im luftbuchungen in den
bilanzen 1,9 milliarden euro
die es wohl nie gegeben hat wenn neuer
kommt tatsächlich umsetze manipuliert
hat dann deutet dies darauf hin dass das
geschäftsmodell von wirecard anderes als
man bislang angenommen hat nicht
profitabel nicht erfolgreich ist
auch wenn viele details noch ungeklärt
sind finanzwissenschaftler erwarten eine
klagewelle
es ist eine der größten pleiten der
bundesrepublik die aufarbeitung kann
jahre dauern
das sind eine ganze reihe von anlegern
geschädigt worden massiv geschädigt
worden
das ist dramatisch weil auch
privatanleger dort investiert waren
institutionelle anleger können sich
häufig besser absichern privatanleger
nicht wir werden anlegerklagen erleben
die gibt es schon es wird eine
beispiellose schlacht vor den gerichten
geben
schlechte aussichten für die
anteilseigner viele aktien sind in
streubesitz
der rasante aufstieg hatte auch viele
kleinanleger angelockt ihr verlust im
märz fast 200 euro war die aktie x wert
heute noch wenige euro an der börse kam
es zu panikverkäufen
die politik alarmiert die bundesanstalt
für finanzdienstleistungsaufsicht in der
kritik unterstellt ist sie dem
bundesfinanzminister der fordert für
seine behörde weitreichende änderungen
ein solcher skandal wie bei wirecard
muss ein weckruf sein dass wir mehr
aufsicht über und kontrolle für die
finanzmärkte brauchen als wir sie heute
haben
das sind wir den aktionärinnen und
aktionären den beschäftigten dieser
unternehmen und insbesondere dem
finanzplatz deutschland uns ein
als bürgerinnen und bürgern schuldig der
staatsanwalt ermittelt gegen markus
braun
er hat eigene firmenanteile kurz nach
seinem rücktritt verkauft für rund 150
millionen euro hat wirecard bekannt
gegebene ja also wenn jemand seine
aktien verkauft dann verlässt er das
sinkende schiff natürlich macht er noch
mal kasse das mit dem glaube ich nichts
nützen das wird vermutlich schon die
strafverfolgungsbehörden gehe ich mal
davon aus dass sie das auch
beschlagnahmen und konfiszieren da gibt
es möglichkeiten mit wirecard steht eine
große börsen hoffnung vor dem aus das
geschäftsmodell eigentlich einfach das
unternehmen hat den bargeldlosen
zahlungsverkehr anderer unternehmen
abgewickelt weltweit pro aktion gegen
eine kleine provision
aber die menge sollte es bringen
geglaubt haben ihm das viele nur so
scheint es stimmt die rechnung nicht
es könnte der größte bilanzskandal in
der deutschen unternehmensgeschichte
werden gibt es einiges heute zu
gesprächen mit dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister danke dass sie
bei uns sind peter altmaier und guten
abend
guten abend herr sievers halt mal
beginnen wir mit wirecard sie haben
gesagt wir hätten eine solche situation
überall erwartet nur nicht in
deutschland
wäre es nicht aufgabe der politik zu
verhindern dass so eine situation
überhaupt eintreten kann
das ist richtig deshalb haben wir
aufsichtsbehörden und ich bin olaf
scholz sehr dankbar dass er die ihm
unterstellte aufsichtsbehörde jetzt auch
bittet die notwendigen konsequenzen zu
ziehen
da muss auch geklärt werden ob man schon
früher hätte wissen können was geschehen
ist warum man es nicht gewusst hat
es tut mir ausgesprochen leid um die
vielen beschäftigten um ihre
arbeitsplätze bangen und es tut mir leid
um die vielen startups in deutschland
die sie von dem bei spielberg art
inspirieren ließen und deren ansehen in
mitleidenschaft gezogen wird das ist ein
großer schaden für den standort
deutschland
der chef der finanzaufsicht hat schon
gesagt das was bei uns gelaufen ist also
bei der aufsicht gelaufen ist das war
ein komplettes desaster
jetzt hätte man das ja tatsächlich schon
viel länger kommen sehen können wer es
denn politisch dafür verantwortlich dass
die aufsicht dabei uns so versagt hat
ist das auch ihr kollege stolz sind sie
das oder wer ist das
der politisch verantwortlichen ende ich
bin ich bin der auffassung dass wir
jetzt nicht partei streit anfangen
sollen sondern dass wir schauen wo
irgendetwas schiefgelaufen ist und dass
wir dann auch ehrlich dazu stehen die
bankenaufsicht hat eine wichtige rolle
sie gehen nichts großes vertrauen und
ich möchte dass das auch in zukunft so
bleibt und deshalb muss die aufklärung
die jetzt auch angekündigt ist auch
autorin und zwar ohne ansehen der person
dem was du mal so ein bisschen größer
vielleicht durch das ist ja nicht das
erste mal dass so etwas passiert paar
namen einfach nur haltmayer hypo real
estate vw siemens schmiergeld skandal
bei ma n dann die deutsche bank die
scheinbar wirklich keinen skandal
ausgelassen hat ist das ganze nicht
vielleicht ein viel größeres und viel
profundes problem haben wir hier ein
strukturproblem
in deutschland ist das management
problem oder ist es einfach nur zu laxe
kontrolle über all überall wo es wo es
um viel geld geht gibt es auch die
versuchung das ein oder andere
vielleicht nicht ganz auf dem legalen
weg zu machen
ein scheitern vielleicht nicht
rechtzeitig ein zu bestehen und das
dürfen wir nicht zulassen
aber hat man noch alle großen namen der
deutschen unternehmensgeschichte das
sind alles nicht ist es ja nicht
irgendwer
aber herr sie was ich will vielleicht
doch noch mal sagen
nach meiner nach meiner einschätzung ist
es so dass wir nicht mehr
es kann dadurch sondern eher weniger
skandale vorzuweisen haben als andere
vergleichbare länder aber das ist keine
entschuldigung
das ist keine entschuldigung weil jeder
einzelne vorgang aufgeklärt werden muss
und er hat im übrigen auch in vielen
fällen damit geendet dass diese
unternehmen dann aufgelöst wurden und
dass sie vom markt verschwunden sind
okay dann haben wir zweites großes thema
heute die lufthansa bevor wir nach vorne
gucken vielleicht ein ganz kurzer blick
zurück können sie garantieren dass die
kunden der lufthansa deren flüge
storniert wurden und die immer noch auf
ihr geld warten obwohl lufthansa ihnen
das eigentlich längst hätte zurückzahlen
müssen
dass die jetzt endlich ihr geld bekommen
es geht immerhin immer noch um eine
milliarde euro
das ist eine rechtliche verpflichtung
der luft
wie die lufthansa arbeitet ein held und
nach allem nach allem was wir wissen
wird die lufthansa dies bedienen sobald
sie über die notwendigen liquiden mittel
verfügt mit dem heutigen tag der in der
geschichte der lufthansa historisch ist
stehen die mittel zur verfügung und ich
erwarte und gehe davon aus dass die
lufthansa ihre verbindlichkeiten bezahlt
so wie jedes andere unternehmen auch
was wird sich jetzt bei der lufthansa
konkret ändern da der staat wir alle
miteigentümer sind können sie jetzt mehr
einfluss nehmen zum beispiel in umwelt
dingen
wir wollen nicht mehr einfluss nehmen
die lufthansa hat sich selbst zur
klimapolitik verpflichtet aber wir
wissen dass der staat nicht der bessere
unternehmer ist deshalb haben wir uns
entschieden die lufthansa zu schützen
gegen übernahme durch feindliche und hat
durchaus bricht durch ausländische
unternehmen mit unlauteren absichten
aber wir greifen nicht in die
unternehmenspolitik 1
das ist glaube ich der richtige weg die
uhr lufthansa war vor dieser krise ein
gesundes unternehmen mit über 100.000
beschäftigten
sie hat gewinne gemacht und da soll sie
auch wieder hin
sie ist ein aushängeschild für den
standort deutschland international
weltweit und das muss auch nach dem ende
der pandemie so bleiben er hat mir das
jetzt politiker nicht sagen hört mal
fliegt bitte aus meinem wahlkreis aus
paderborn zum beispiel jetzt nonstop
nach new york das macht sicherlich sind
aber es gibt auch ziele auf die wir uns
alle verständigen könnten zb konkrete
umweltauflagen also verzicht auf
innerdeutsche flüge zum beispiel und wer
geld gibt wie der staat wie wir alle
jetzt dann müsste doch auch
mitspracherecht haben und mitsprechen
dürfen oder sie was ich kann ihre frage
zwar verstehen dass sie verkennt die
rolle des staates ist der staat macht
auflagen durch gesetze diese gesetze
gelten dann für alle unternehmen egal ob
sie gerettet werden oder nicht und wir
haben eine sehr ehrgeizige
klimaschutzpolitik wir haben uns das
ziel gesetzt die emissionen zu
reduzieren
wir werden in der nächsten woche im
bundestag den kohle ausstieg endgültig
beschließen
wir werden unsere ziele die wir uns
gesetzt haben auch für das jahr 2020
einhalten
das gilt dann für alle aber wir mischen
uns nicht in die entscheidungen eines
einzelnen unternehmens die darüber dann
maßgeblich sind ob dieses unternehmen
eine gute oder schlechte
geschäftspolitik macht wenn wir das
täten würde das vertrauen in diese
unternehmen aber auch das vertrauen in
den staat leiden und das wollen wir auf
jeden fall vermeiden da sind der
finanzminister und der
wirtschaftsminister die ganze
bundesregierung sich einig und der
wirtschaftswelt ist aber heute abend
live im heute-journal peter altmaier
herzlichen dank nach berlin ich danke
ihnen zwei wichtige corona nachrichten
stehen am beginn der übersicht jetzt mit
karsai
die europäische arzneimittelbehörde ema
empfiehlt zum ersten mal die zulassung
eines medikaments gegen cupid 19
dabei geht es um rossi wir ein mittel
das ursprünglich gegen ebola entwickelt
wurde
eine internationale studie hatte gezeigt
dass es die genesung von bestimmten
patienten beschleunigt nämlich solchen
die zusätzlichen sauerstoff brauchen
aber nicht künstlich beatmet werden
müssen
die nötige zustimmung der eu-kommission
gilt als formsache
im groner brennpunkt gütersloh haben
sich zahlreiche bewohner freiwillig
testen lassen und die ergebnisse geben
hoffnung von 2000 tests sei nur ein
einziger positiv ausgefallen das sagte
nordrhein westfalens gesundheitsminister
laumann in dem stark betroffenen
landkreis werden die testmöglichkeiten
massiv ausgeweitet so können sich die
bürger in einem drive im zentrum auf das
virus testen lassen und dabei im auto
bleiben
das bundesschiedsgericht der afg hat
offenbar entschieden dass andreas
kalbitz die partei vorerst verlassen
soll
mehrere vorstandsmitglieder bestätigten
dem zdf einen entsprechenden bericht der
bundesvorstand hatte den brandenburger
landeschef aus der partei ausgeschlossen
was das landgericht berlin für
unzulässig erklärte erst müsse die
entscheidung des parteiinternen
hauptsacheverfahrens abgewartet werden
kalbitz wird vorgeworfen eine
mitgliedschaft in der rechtsextremen
heimattreuen deutschen jugend
verschwiegen zu haben
in deutschland leben rund 68.000 frauen
und mädchen deren genitalien verstümmelt
wurden das zeigen
neue zahlen die bundesfamilienministerin
giffey vorstellte demnach stieg die zahl
der betroffenen in den vergangenen drei
jahren und 44 die meisten von ihnen
stammen aus eritrea somalia indonesien
ägypten und nigeria und wurden noch in
ihrer heimat verstümmelt als grund für
den anstieg nannte giffey die stärkere
zuwanderung aus diesen staaten
bundesinnenminister seehofer verzichtet
auf eine strafanzeige gegen eine touch
kolumnistin statt dessen suchte er nun
das gespräch mit der redaktion
er sei aber weiterhin der auffassung
dass durch die menschenverachtende
wortwahl auch straftatbestände erfüllt
werden
inzwischen hat der presserat ein
verfahren gegen die tageszeitung
eingeleitet die autorin hatte sinngemäß
geschrieben sie halte müllhalden für
geeignete orte für polizisten
es ist die grösste verfassungsreform in
der geschichte russlands und ab heute
können die bürger darüber abstimmen
mehr als 110 millionen wahlberechtigte
sind zu dem referendum aufgerufen
mit der reform dürfte präsident putin
bis 2036 im amt bleiben zwölf jahre
länger als bisher erlaubt außerdem würde
er weitere machtbefugnisse erhalten
umstritten ist auch dass die ehe auf
mann und frau beschränkt werden soll und
die homo-ehe damit per verfassung
verboten werden so jetzt lernen wir nah
sanín mohammad und amir kennen drei
kinder die schule in deutschland
überhaupt leben in deutschland bislang
vor allem unter einem aspekt kennen den
anschluss schaffen und dann den
anschluss nicht verlieren das ist schwer
wenn man mit der deutschen sprache bei
null beginnen muss in einer
flüchtlingsunterkunft lebt und es dann
heißt corona die schulen schließen
schule zu hause ist auch für millionen
deutscher schüler eine herausforderung
und die haben ein echtes zuhause wo mein
sani mohammad und armee die beim
homeschooling in ihrer hamburger wohnung
kunst zum arbeiten teilen sich die
geschwister immer den wohnzimmertisch
wir hatten der sie bei schwierigkeiten
unterstützen kann gibt es nicht
da stehen etwas was ich nicht verstehen
kann in der schule konnte ich mein
lehrer fragen was das bedeutet oder so
und die könnten mehr erklären
aber zu hause geht das nicht denn seine
eltern sprechen kaum deutsch
mariam und ali mohammad theorie sind vor
vier jahren aus afghanistan geflüchtet
sie selbst haben nie eine schule besucht
dass sie ihre kinder nicht unterstützen
können mache sie traurig es gibt niemand
nicht hier der den kindern helfen kann
deutsche muttersprachler können die
rolle eines lehrers viel besser
übernehmen
unsere kinder dagegen sind durch diese
situation sehr weit zurückgefallen in
weit mehr als der hälfte aller hamburger
flüchtlingsunterkünfte gibt es keinen
kostenfreien wlan anschluss familie timo
die zeit fürs internet aus eigener
tasche
doch es fehlt ein computer und asiens
lehrerin hat der familie geholfen geld
für einen laptop zu beantragen ich habe
ja kein handy und ich konnte mehr spiele
machen google benutzen und schreiben
doch ein laptop so das amt gehören nicht
zum sogenannten regelbedarf der antrag
wurde abgelehnt
schlechte grundvoraussetzungen für
erfolgreiches homeschooling und
mangelnde deutschkenntnisse yamaha siri
bekommt durch seinen intensiven kontakt
zu geflüchteten oft verzweiflung und
überforderung mit
wir haben eine extreme spaltung der
schüler also das nennt sich eine
spreizung diese spreizung findet darin
den bereich dass die kinder die
eigentlich den lehrer gebraucht haben
die unterstützung gebraucht haben die
emotionale stabilität die bindung
gebraucht haben
die sind vollkommen jetzt
aus den bildungsprozess vollkommen raus
das homeschooling verschärft ein problem
das es schon vor der korona krise gab
bildungszugang und erfolg hängen jetzt
noch stärker von der sozialen herkunft
ab die schulbehörde in hamburg teilt auf
anfrage mit verschiedene maßnahmen
ergriffen zu haben um kinder aus
flüchtlingsfamilien besser zu
unterstützen
zum beispiel haben hamburgs schulen aus
dem digital pack 2 rund 37.000
zusätzliche tablets bestellt mit denen
auch schülerinnen und schüler aus
flüchtlingsunterkünften versorgt werden
sollen
noch sind die geräte nicht dafür neu
sahen ihn und mohammad wäre ein laptop
eine hilfe
doch fest steht auch die schule muss
sich in besonderem maße um kinder ohne
häusliche unterstützung kümmern damit
sie den anschluss nicht endgültig
verlieren wenn ein medizinisch gebotenen
schutz zum politikum wird dann sagt das
einiges über die zeiten und die welt in
der wir leben und zwar nichts gutes es
war schon länger abzusehen und das wird
immer deutlicher
viele von denen die demonstrativ keine
maske auf haben in den usa selbst
inmitten von menschenmengen wollen damit
auch zeigen wir stehen hinter donald
trump wer umgekehrt eine maske trägt der
schützt damit nicht nur sich und andere
der sendet in den augen vieler trump
anhänger auch das signal ich bin nicht
einverstanden mit der politik des
präsidenten
wohin so was führt in einem land das
weiterhin dramatisch viele corona
infektionen und tote zu beklagen hat
zeigt el mati wissen was immer donald
trump auch macht es scheint als gäbe es
ein masken verbot selbst bei der
kranzniederlegung heute morgen und wenn
wie in palm beach county florida masken
pflicht beschlossen wird dann passiert
das
[Musik]
als wäre die maske ein werkzeug der
unterdrückung dabei steigen die
ansteckungsraten in 23 bundesstaaten
deutlich an
der gouverneur von texas hatte früh im
mai die beschränkungen gelockert jetzt
sind die krankenhäuser an der grenze und
der fleht es gibt keinen grund dass sie
ihre häuser verlassen außer wenn man es
wirklich muss menschen wollen keine
maske tragen besonders den
republikanisch regierten bundesstaaten
schießen die infektionszahlen hoch das
ist beunruhigend
aber wir kriegen nicht alle fakten zum
beispiel wie viel mehr getestet wird als
sei der anstieg nur den test geschuldet
die langen schlangen an den test
stationen zeigen dass die pandemie jetzt
neu in fahrt kommt trotzdem will die
trump regierung die bundeshilfe für die
tests streichen
das ist ganz besonders und
verantwortlich zusätzlich zur ignoranz
zu den wahnvorstellungen die von trump
und seinem team verbreitet werden
der präsident befeuert die
gleichgültigkeit wie hier in arizona bei
einer studenten kundgebung fast ohne
masken trump reißt witze über den namen
der krankheit
cobit 19 warum 19 manche können nicht
erklären woher die 19 kommt wir werden
stärker sein als je zuvor und zwar bald
[Applaus]
ich verstehe nicht warum das weiße haus
trotz der tatsachen im land so
ahnungslos tun
das ist unerklärlich es sei denn es geht
um knallharte parteipolitik während wir
in eine gesundheitskrise steuern wie
wichtig die masken sind zeigt die
statistik denn dort wo seit wochen
zehntausende demonstrierten die meisten
mit maske sind die infektionsraten nicht
deutlich angestiegen anders als da wo
die menschen ohne jeden schutz
zusammenkamen um so wichtiger sind es
joe biden der wahlkampf mit
sicherheitsabstand macht ist empört dass
trump die gelder für die test streicht
trump kann die pandemie nicht wegwischen
nicht für politische zwecke
zurechtbiegen es wird keine wunder geben
der präsident will gleich in wisconsin
in einer town hall über den zitat
übergang zu neuer größe reden mit vielen
gästen und angeblich mit masken pflicht
und wir schauen an dieser stelle nochmal
auf die ereignisse bei wirecard diesmal
mit dem blick auf die börse
denn dass ein dax unternehmen so in die
knie geht das hat es in dieser form noch
nie gegeben
wie reagieren die anleger frank bethmann
erneut sind sie fassungslos die aktie
stürzt weiter ab am ende ist es heute
der zweit höchste verlust den jemals
eine aktie im dax hier eingefahren hat
ausgerechnet war ja klar die papiere
gehörten gerade bei den privatanlegern
zu den beliebtesten im dax ist das
kartenhaus zusammenbrach der schaden ist
groß immerhin kommen die mit einem
schrecken davon
die mit ihrem geld nicht auf wirecard
aktien sondern auf die wirecard bank
gesetzt haben der zahlungsdienstleister
teilte heute mit die wirecard bank ag
ist nicht teil des insolvenzverfahrens
der wirecard ag über ihre banking app
boom planet sammelt wirecard
kundengelder ein und bietet unter
anderem ein girokonto an dass die bank
seit anfang des jahres mit einem
guthabenzins von 0,75 prozent bewirkt
die finanzaufsicht bafin hat inzwischen
einen sonderbeauftragten für die bank
eingesetzt der über die zahlungsströme
wacht immerhin hier hat es schnell
klarheit gegeben wie es hingegen mit der
insolventen bank hat an der börse
weitergeht ist offen
wahrscheinlich bleibt das skandal
unternehmen noch bis zum dritten
september im dax als dax-mitglied erst
dann wird der dax wieder überprüft und
bislang sieht das bestehende regelwerk
einen früheren rausschmiss vor
sein kern die frankfurter börse die
frauenfußball-wm 2023 findet in
australien und neuseeland statt mit
ihrer gemeinsamen bewerbung setzten sich
die länder gegen kolumbien durch
damit wird erstmals eine frauen-wm auf
der südhalbkugel ausgetragen ebenfalls
zum ersten mal nehmen 32 teams teil
heute vor 70 jahren griff nordkorea
überraschend südkorea an
damit begann ein dreijähriger krieg in
dem millionen
starben oder vertrieben wurden heute
haben beide länder an die opfer erinnert
auf beiden seiten der entmilitarisierten
zone versammelten sich politiker und
veteranen 1953 vereinbarten nord und
südkorea zwar einen waffenstillstand
doch technisch befinden sie sich bis
heute im kriegszustand
singen ist gesund es stärkt die
abwehrkräfte es macht ausgeglichener und
zufriedener
das ist wissenschaftlich belegt singen
ist hochgefährlich je lauter je länger
und je länger ein chor zusammenkommt
desto höher das risiko sich mit dem
corona virus anzustecken es gibt
furchtbare beispiele dafür
gesangsvereine die nach einer probe fast
komplett infiziert war
was tun ein unauflösbarer gegensatz
nein sagen die menschen in brüssel die
immer schon besonders erfinderisch waren
wenn es darum geht aus widrigen lagen
das beste zu machen
dort nimmt uns mit im altehrwürdigen
jubel park genießen die brüssler die
freiheit die ihnen so lange verwehrt
der tanz und sport clubs noch
geschlossen sind wird im lichte der
öffentlichkeit trainiert in einer ecke
probt zum zweiten mal nun schon der
königliche protestantische chor
[Musik]
hier können die sänger abstand halten
das wäre im probenraum unmöglich über
müller außerdem wird die musik dorthin
gebracht wo sie normalerweise nicht ist
leute hören die musik die wahrscheinlich
nie oder selten in concert
[Musik]
jung und alt staunen ganz unverblümt
oder heimlich
wer zeit hat lässt sich nieder
es ist angenehm wir sind hier zufällig
lang gelaufen und finden es witzig kann
ich das nur aus der kirche oder aus dem
konzert sei aber dass das so toll klingt
im offenen das finde ich ganz toll
es geht nicht um perfektion bei diesen
proben sondern um zusammen seien alle
singen nur in ihrer freizeit und doch
sind die konzertsäle ausverkauft wenn
der chor auftritt
dort werden sie auch von einem orchester
begleitet ein paar geht es spartanischer
zu und es gilt so manche schwierigkeit
zu meistern ist ein bisschen schwer weil
wir uns gegenseitig nicht hören ich höre
die bässe und tenöre nicht weil sie zu
weit wechseln am anfang muss man sich an
den lärm rundrum gewöhnen wenn man sich
entspannt singt man lauter und
vielleicht sogar sauberer als sonst
[Musik]
wer den chor bei seinen proben entdeckt
kann für einen moment die sorgen des
alltags vergessen und einfach nur
genießen dass dieser abend in brüssel zu
bieten hat
[Musik]
tolle idee damit entlassen wir sie in
diesen abend in deutschland und in eine
hoch interessante runde bei maybrit
illner feindbild polizei hass gewalt und
machtmissbrauch fragezeichen was und wer
steckt hinter der nächtlichen
gewaltwelle in der stuttgarter
innenstadt jetzt gleich nach uns danke
für das interesse an unserem heute
journal am donnerstag
[Musik]
er nahm meine damen und herren immer
drängender wird die frage wie denn nun
der sommer wird droht uns ein dürre
sommer wie 2018 oder gibt es ende juli
hitzerekorde wie im letzten jahr mit
über 40 grad
im augenblick sieht das alles noch nicht
danach aus da sieht das ja doch eher
recht normal aus bis jetzt für die
nächsten ein zwei wochen weitergeht gibt
es eher wechselhaftes wetter aber warmes
wetter so auch aktuell das hoch und das
verabschiedet sich nämlich nach osten
und tiefe silvia übernimmt bringt
regenschauer und gewitter und die
beschäftigen uns das ganze wochenende
über heute nacht fällt erstmal nur wenig
regen noch am alpenrand in der feuchten
luft bildet sich allerdings auch mal
nebel
das wird eine laue sommernacht vor allen
dingen am rhein und an den küsten von
nord- und ostsee
sinken die werte zum teil nicht unter 9
10 bis 17 grad
die nacht in bayern mit elf bis 9 grad
und morgen klettern die werte auf
schweißtreibende 25 grad an der ostsee
und bis 33 grad am rhein und schon am
vormittag beginnt es dann mit schauern
und gewittern
die ziehen hier über ost sachsen
brandenburg und berlin bis nach
mecklenburg vorpommern und ab den
mittagsstunden beginnt es dann auch im
südwesten zu brodeln von frankreich und
luxemburg her breiten sich schauer und
gewitter aus es gibt allerdings morgen
auch viel sonne und zwar zwischen sylt
und dem bayerischen wald die gewitter
können durchaus unwetterartig sein und
solche unwetterartige gewitter haben wir
auch noch am samstag der sonntag wird
ruhiger der montag kühler
schönen abend noch